طبعا يعني انا بدايه حاسس ان انا العجوز
ابوار وسط الشباب بالذات ان جميع الناس
اللي اكلموا قبليه كنت حاسس كده الناس
بتتكلم على 10 سنين و 20 سنه انا بسرعه
كده انا من عمر تد يعني هو بدا 1984 انا
اتخرجت
1984 الناس كانت بتتكلم انها مواليد 82
انا مواليد 62 يمكن شويه الواحد لما
بيتكلم يحس
ان الواحد بين الينين بين الشباب اللي هو
دايما القضيه القضيه بتاعته والحياه
بتاعته كلها دايما بفكر ازاي هو
يكون ك حياته ان هو مشي فيها ان هو يمهد
الطريق في المرحله اللي احنا فيها دي اول
امبارح جالي تليفون من واحده من الاعزاء
اللي موجودين في البي ودي بتقوللي يا
دكتور احنا عندنا بعد بكره تدرس فلها
انا ما كنتش اعرف لكن انا كنت جاي من
الاقصر ولما جيت من
الاقصر كنت في اللقصر علشان بحاول ان انا
اعمل دعوه لمبتين عالميتين الهدف منهم
تمكين الشباب والبحث العلمي وخبره
الدراسات فعود تروح الوعي ومعاها محصل
المصريين بكل الامكانات الكلوس والفرص
اللي موجوده فيها
المسابقه اللي احنا اتكلمنا فيها كان
مسابقتين زي ما احنا كنا بنقول عليه كان
بملازمه افتتاح مقبره توت عن خمود المقلده
فيص كان في 20 سفير كان في وزراء كان في
اعلام واحنا بعو لمسابقه موجوده في
البرقد اللي موجودين فيه في الاقص
النهارده مافيش سياحه فعلا حاجه كان تحزن
جدا انت ماشي مش لاقي سياح
خالص في نفس الوقت عندك بيئه ومكان على
اعلى مستوى تتينه الحضاره اللي موجوده
فيها في نفس الوقت كان في احتفاليات وكسته
القاهره الفرعوني بيتكلموا في الموضوع ده
واحنا عايزين نعمل مسابقتين انا بدات بال
مسابقتين مهع بقى لكل المحاولات اللي
الواحد بيعملها في حياته او بيسعى فيها
ازاي ان احنا الشباب في القضايا القوميه
احنا عندنا في
بلادنا حاله من الحالات اللي مش هتتكرر
كتير ان احنا لقينا في 25 يناير حاله
بترقب التغير والتغيير كان في صديق من
شويه كان بيقول في فرق بين التغير التغيير
والتحولات هنقدر نقول عليها تغير التغيير
او التحولات لكن على اساس ايه تكلمنا عن
الشباب هم اللي عملوا المستحيل جيلي وجيل
اللي اكبر مني وقف مرحله ان هي مالهاش حال
وللاسف اللي احنا فيه دلوقتي في مرحله
التراجع بسبب جيلي وجيل اللي اكبر مني بر
لكن لسه الواحد بيقول الشباب من غير
الشباب مش هيحصل عمليه التغير التغييري كل
قضيه من قضايانا عشان نغير لازم نيكون
الشباب بس في نفس الوقت العلم والتعليم
والبحث ال طب عندنا طريقتين في الموضوع ده
الطريقه الاولانيه نبتدي العلم منما قبل
ما بتتعلم يعني انت في قبل كده لحد ما
تتخرج ودي بطاريه تعليم هتحتاج 10 سنين
ولا 20 سنه بس مشكله ان تبتدي بالطفل اللي
هيبتدي يتعلم تلاقي يعلمه فدي محتاجه
دايرين البديل التاني اللي دايما الواحد
بيتكلم فيه ان احنا ممكن بالعلم والتعليم
المتكامل انا اعرف 10% انت تعرف 5% في حد
يعرف 3% ونشوف قضايانا ايه فكانت القضيه
التانيه اللي احنا اتكلمنا فيها والنهارده
مش وقت خالص بالنسبه لقسم العماره في
الجامعه البريطانيه وفي جامعات اخرى كان
بيتقال ان في قناه السياس احد الفرص
الواعده لمستقبل مصري بس هم لما بيتكلموا
بها بيتكلموا من توب داون ماحدش بيتكلم
على مين البني ادم اللي هيعيش هناك وهيعيش
فين فكانت من المحاولات قريبه جدا واللي
احنا شغالين فيها ان احنا يبقى عندنا رؤيه
لانسان والمجتمعات السويس دايما نتكلم بقى
على تمكين شباب محيه مصر المصريين هو في
فرق بين المح الاميه بان احنا بنتكلم على
تعرف تقرا وتكتب لكن مح مصر المصريين لو
نسمع عن جمال حمدان لو نسمع عن وصف مصر
اللي كتبوه الفرنساويين لو نسمع عن كل
الدراسات اللي بتتعمل على مصر مين يعرف
فينا الثروات اللي موجوده في سينا مين
يعرف فينا الثروات الموجوده في الشمالي او
في الصحرا الغربيه احنا محتاجين نعرف
الكلام ده محتاجين نحس بيه عايزين الخروج
كلمه الخروج كان احد القضايا اللي الناس
كتيره لو دخلت في النت تلاقينا كنا بنتكلم
فيها وعملنا مسابه وكانت على المصرح ده
الخروج هنا هو بافكار جديده بس الاول
الخروج ببني ادم
مختلف الخروج
بالواجب احنا قاعدين في 5% من مساحه الارض
عندنا 95% مانه
ثروات قبل ما نفكر بقى ان احنا عايزين اخر
وعايزين نبني حضاره لازم نفكر في بناد
الحضاره كانت كل دي القضيه المجه عندنا
دايما لازم احنا دايما بكلم ان احنا
عايزين نغير بس المواجهه والمنور كل وقت ض
في الواي بالحبات الواجي الانسان اللي
يتعود على مشاكل ومش عارف يطلع منها ين
كده زي ماكون فيرام متحرك عملين يكون فيه
بعتبرها نوع من المور نكسب وقت نكسب وقت
ليه ماحدش عارف هل هو الوقت اللي احنا
نكسب هدي النهارده هيشتغل بكره هيشتغل بع
بعد ال فتره بتاخر لكن افضل ان احنا نفكر
في مصر اخرى مساحات اخرى اللي هي
95% وعشان كده كان الرسول من يتقي الله
يجعل له ب شخص بقاع ده الواد ده طلع منو
بس عارفين كان ده الرشيد وكان دي دمياط
وكان ده الوال وهو
عايزه لما ببص على مساحتنا احنا ما بقاش
في مكان نعيش فيه ما بقاش عندنا مكان نموت
فيه لو عايز تروح من مشوار لمشوار بتاخد
لك لاث اربع ساعات 85% من مساحه الارض
بتاعتنا مباني المبنيه محتاجه تتغير
وعندنا تلوث طبعا الصوره هنا مش موجوده
عندنا مشاكل الميه وصراعات سد النهضه و
قبل سد النهضه عندنا مشاكل وعندنا لسه ناس
لحد دلوقتي قاعده تعيش بطبيعتها وفي حاجه
اسمها
الينج 8 من دول ل 10 من دول المفروضين
عايشين على السواحل بتاعت نا المفروض انهم
ينتقر هيروحوا فين احنا محتاجين نفكر قبل
طوفان نوح ما يحصل طوفان نوح احنا هاته في
بعض ع نجييب محفوظ بيقول عليها ثوره
الحرافيش احنا لما بنتكلم هنا بنقول سفينه
نوح احنا محتاجين نبني نقط جديده نعيش
فيها تبقى بالنسبه لمصر كانها سفينه نوح
حصلت الص كلها شهله كانت قايمه بالشباب
وبين المناوره والمواجهه في ناس بتقول لك
انا الحكومه في واحد بيقف نبني مستقبل
مفور يتم ازاي عندنا شباب بيخ في بيخرج في
سواحل ايطاليا وبيضرب قدامها يوميا 100
120 وفي بيض بوه في صحراء ليبيا واللي حظه
احسن شويه يقعد يعيش 20 ل 30 سنه من عمره
في الخليج علشان يغير حاله رغم ربنا يعنيي
ان احنا في مصر عندنا كميه روات وجيات
تخلينا احنا نغرق العالم
كله الخروج كلمه الناس تستغربها فيناس
وبطها بخروج سيدنا موسى بس الواحد عايز
يقول ان الخروج من ايام اخناتون خنتور كان
عنده ديانه كيله فكان لازم يخرج من طيبه
اللي هي نقص اللي بنتكلم عليها ويبن تل
العمل قسطنطين عشان نخلي الجاله المسيحيه
دياله الدوله الرومانيه كان لازم يترك
روما ل يعلنها في قسطنطينه ثم ت فاتيكان
سيدنا محمد الخروج لو نبص الره وهو بيخرج
من مكه قاللك لولا اخرجوني ما خرجت كان
بالنسبه لكفار قريش ده الانتصار
لوس لكن بالنسبه
للاسلام انطلاق الدعوه وانتشارها في نقطه
جديده تتقبل صبل العايش اللي هي اصبحت
المدينه المنوره الخروج هي نوع جديد من
الحياه يسمح لنا كلنا ان احنا نقدر نفكر
بطريقه ايجابيه العالم كله دلوقتي بقى
بيتعود مع بعضين ما نقدرش نفكر وحدينا في
الدنيا اللي احنا بنتعامل معاها بقى لازم
نبص نشوف خبرات الدول اللي سبتنا
وخبرات تخلينا نحل ونقبل الالزم افكار
احنا بنتكلم على كوالتي لايف كل واحد فينا
ممكن يبقى ليه دور فيها وبالتالي واحنا
بنفكر في اتجاهات متعدده في تخصصات متعدده
نقدر نبدي دور بدور لازم نعرف ان الكلام
ده هيتم امونيك يعني ايه ستيب باي ستيب
احنا بنحاول ساعات في الجامعه عندنا او
بنحاول في اماكن اخرى او من خلال
المسابقات او الواحد راجع من الاقصر ان
احنا نوجد شباب يبقى ابتدي عنده اليقين ان
احنا بنبني بعضنا مع بعض يحصل عمليه
التمكين ونبطل الفاز اللوجيك احنا عايشين
الاشاره الحمراء هي اللي بنمشي معاها
والاشاره الخضرا بنقف
الدنيا بالنسبه لنا بقت متاها ونقرب مع
بعض ونعمل بريج ولينك وابني ابنك تموش
ارسو كان ليه كلمه لطيفه جدا قاللك عشان
تربي ايه انت محتاج تربي ابويه وجدود
الاربعه ودي تحتاج 100 سنه احنا ماعدناش
نقدر 100 سنه احنا بالتقنيه النهارده نقدر
نقرب المسافات بالتكنولوجيا نقدر نقرب
الامور هنا لما جت فكره المسابقات انا
اقوللكم الفكره جت لما كنت رئيس قسم عماره
في جامعه المنصوره جتلي مسابقه اسمها
القدس عاصمه السلام 20 50 4000 فريق في
العالم اشترك في الرؤيه دي انتم عارفين
اسرايل كسبت ايه راي عام عالمي سنه 20 50
كل الشباب والمجتمع اللي دخلوا مقتنعين
القدس عاصمه اسرائيل عاصمه
السبب هنا الواحد كتب محاضرات
عمل مقالات كل مقاله بيبقى ليها قمتها
وبيبقى ليها مردودها في اللي قدنا لكن
بالنسبه للشباب عشان نصنع شباب جديد افكار
جديده كل واحد فينا يلاقي المجال كانت هي
دي القلم لحد ما جه في يوم من الايام سنه
2003 لقيت البيراميد اوف جابان البيراميد
اوف جابان ده في اليابان عندهم مشكله
الكوبليشن في تكي ومحتاجين انهم يلاقوا حل
وما عندهمش ارض وبداوا يفكروا ويتحدوا
الحضاره المصريه بالهرم بتاع الحضاره
المصريه هو ايه اللي
حصل عايزين
الهرم بتاع البيراميد جابان بقت مدينه
تتسع ل 750 ال بني ادم بكل التكنولوجيا
بكل التخصصات بكل العلم اللي ممكن تتخيله
بكل العلم من اماكن فتلاقي فكره جايه من
ايطاليا فكره جايه من استراليا فكره جايه
من اسكوتلندا فكره جايه فقدره مع بعض
توشيب الفكره اللي احنا بنتكلم عليها في
الهرم بتاع جبان وقالوا لو كان هرم مصر
اللي مديه حضاره ده قعد 5000 سنه فهم
كانوا عايزين يعملوا بالنانو تكنولوجي
وبدي
وبانسب مبنى يبقى مدينه يقعد 5 الف سنه كل
دراساتهم وافكارهم دي خليت الواحد يقول هم
عندهم الحاله دي بالتقنيه بامكانياته احنا
في مصر عندنا البديل احنا عندنا صح
فعايزين بنفس الكونسبت بنفس الرؤيه بنفس
الفكر يبقى عندنا القدره على ان احنا
نبتدي نتحدى كلمه التشالنج بقت موجوده
كلمه الوجي بقت موجوده يمكن الفيديو مش
هيسمح لكن هو ده ازاي يبتدي عمليه التمكين
هل هيتم بفرض ولا لازم بمجموعات ازاي نقدر
نوصل لحاجه كان موضوع الخروج اكدت لنا ان
احنا خروج او مؤتمرات او دراسات وكل علماء
مصر بافكارهم يبق هم دول مستندات الطرح
يعني ايه كل واحد قال فكره بقى الشباب
يقراوا كلمه من هنا ويقرا كلمه من هنا
وديمقراطيه البحث العلمي يعني الستفي كيشن
العلميه هي اللي ترجح ما بقاش في بقى
الجزء السياسي موجود انت ممكن تجيب فكره
من مسلم من مسيحي من اخوان من متحضر من هو
العلم الاساس تجيبه من اسرائيل تجيبه من
هند تجيبه من الصين هو العلم بقى الاساس
بقينا عملنا تمكين للعلم وبقى عندنا
ديمقراطيه في عمليه التقدير في كل العلوم
فبدا يطلع شباب عملوا الخريطه الجهنميه دي
53 نقطه تتقبل سبل العيش لمجتمعات مستدامه
شباب اللي طلعوها وقالوها في المسرح
ده وكل مجموعه كان عندها مبرراتها العلميه
وحاجه تستطيع انك تفتخر ان احنا عندنا
شباب ما استناش الاذن وكان
مبادر الكلام ده بيرتبط انك بتطلع كل سنه
بماتريكس والماتركس دي تتكامل فيها الرؤى
للدراسات ولما بداوا يتكلموا النهارده على
قناه السويس كان عندنا من ثلاث سنين افكار
40% من افكار الشباب بديمقراطية
كل الدراسات اللي طلعت دي والمحاولات اللي
بقت في الجرايد وفي التلفزيون وفي الاعلام
اللي احنا بنقولها وكان هنا الاحتفاليه
الدام اللي موجود خدت الواحد يقول طيب
احنا النهارده في المحاولات اللي احنا
بنعملها العالم كله دلوقتي بيعمل ترشن
احنا بنتكلم على الحضاره اللي نقصد كانت
حاله بقى نخلي الكلام اللي كان هيب شويه
على نقط جديده تتكبر صب العيش نختار
الاقصل اليوم 30 ابريل قلنا عندنا مسابقه
هيشترك فيها الشاب المصري قبل حاجه الشاب
الاقصري مع شباب العالم في ان احنا نفكر
في معنى جديد للكوتي اوف لايف للاقصر نهتم
بها بانسان الاقصر وبعدين السياحه تيجي
بعد كده فدي كانت المسابقه الاولى في
الوقت ان كل القضايا بتاع الترانزيشن اللي
بتحصل في العالم نقدر نوظفها في المسابقه
دي المسابقه التانيه كانت القصر اللي احنا
بنتكلم عليها في العالم كله كانت ممكن
تبقى اكتر من براند هي مالهاش براند فبد
اناا نتكلم على الاص وحقوق الملكيه
الفكريه دي كانت القضيه عايز اقولكم بس ان
النجمه بتاع لاس فيجاس دي فوق ين نجمه
داوود هو بيقوللي خلصت انا بس ععرض
بسرعه الحاجات ليه حقوق المكيه الفكريه
لان اوريدي التراث بتاع البراند في العالم
كله واحنا ما
بنوفو لما تيجي في وقت تاني بس عايز اعدي
ده عايزين نعدي بسين اللي بعد كده احنا
لازم نفكر في الطفل بتاع بكره فانتوا بقى
عندكم المسؤوليه اللي هي دايما بتبقى عندي
مسؤوليه لان الظروف بتاع بكره هتبقى
مختلفه هنحاول نحاول الكلام ده كمان ل
جيمز يلعبوه الاطفال في المستقبل عملنا
محاولات لعمليات الجيمز احنا بنفكر دلوقتي
في ان عشان نكتب تاريخ المستقبل مش زي ما
الجامعه اليه
بتقول التمكين لثوره ل تبدا بعد انا
بشكركم واتمنى في يوم من الايام ان كلنا
مع بعض
شكرا